um yeah who else is dope this year what
albums did you like
future had the best album under here to
me
I respect the opinion just to me yeah to
me besides results you got him you got
you were number two there [ __ ] I
got me in one [ __ ] I got me you know
let's just dropped a great album
Uncle few
oh the Migos uh was really good the uh
yeah no it's still it's dope Angie
herbal's album is she herbo's dope
um yeah no the uh
I'm very sad about the Bingo's breakup
to be honest but what happened I don't
know they're all related bro so I don't
get it you know what happened tell
people what happened I don't know what
happened I mean I think it was all about
money contracts QC [ __ ] I don't know
well I don't know but I love I love man
damn that's so sad I love how they
recreated the rayquan I think I think
it's good
why I think sometimes certain things run
its course
but they're related yeah but I think my
thing is if they break up and it's like
amicable they're not it's fine officer
is not related to them oh they're he's
not Cleveland take off his release I
thought they aren't always related in
some companies I think cuevos takeoff's
nephew correct no I think cuevo is
takeoff's Uncle yes okay that's one of
them but offset was the homie are we
sure yes are we sure yes
they're all related they're all related
yeah no they're all related they can't
all be related
no no no no cuevos don't they can't all
be related
Google it Dwight come on they can't all
be related they're all related no
they're not quavo and takeoff is related
officer it's the homie what was the
homie look it up
a guarantee
this people's cousin
cousin
I told you we're both of them well I
knew that they were related damn no
that's a great album though yeah now I
listened to it yesterday it was real
good rock Marciano has Adobe album with
Alchemist yeah stove God cooking up some
dope [ __ ] too I just seen him the other
day in New York the uh
Rome streets almost dope too shout out
to him